he was a philosopher self-help author
and motivational speaker
his first book your erroneous zones is
one of the best-selling books of all
time his message resonated with many in
the new thought movement and beyond
he is Wayne Dyer and here's my take on
his top 10 rules of success volume 2
rule number 3 is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in the comments below put quotes
around it to other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
you as well
enjoy
creative visualization is what we're
talking about here you the imagery or
the image that you have of anything in
your life is really like mental behavior
it's like going out in practicing if you
go out and practice with a basketball
shooting free-throws over and over again
that's physical practice imagery is
mental practice it's a mental behavior
when you have an image that you can
succeed at something when you have an
image that you can do it rather than
that you can't do it when you get into
your car and you have an image that
you're going to find a parking place
rather than that there'll be no place to
park so you're not looking for no place
to park you will start acting on the
image that you have very much like you
will start acting on the practice that
you have when you're shooting baskets or
when you're hitting a forehand ER or
working on your soup or anything else
that you're doing the telling moment of
my life occurred on the 30th of August
1974 when I went to my father's grave
after finding out he had been dead for
10 years and I went there with a
different intention on what I was going
to do on his grave I was so filled with
rage and anger and hatred toward this
man but rather than do what I had gone
there to do something some invisible
divine organizing intelligence that
moves the planet and grows your
fingernails and beats your heart that
commander in the command center to which
you are always connected your I am
presence if you will called me back to
his grave after I cursed him for two
hours on that Friday afternoon and I
stood there and I said from this moment
on I send your love Who am I Who am I to
judge you you did what you knew how to
do given the conditions of your life and
when I left that gravesite I was a
completely changed man the alcohol
hasn't touched my lips since that day
I walked away from it I got myself into
the best shape of my life I began
running and relationships began to
change the right people the right woman
came into my life my children began to
appear because when you advanced
confidently in the direction of your own
dreams and endeavor to live the life
which you have imagined you will meet
with a success unexpected in common
hours everything about my life changed
my writing took on a whole different
flavor before I was stuck I checked into
a motel room the spindrift motel and a
1a and Fort Lauderdale Florida and I
wrote a book that today has over a
hundred million copies in print and 47
languages called your erroneous owns it
came because the rage was gone
Mark Twain once said that forgiveness is
the fragrance let the violet shed on the
heel that has crushed it that's divine
love my friend Byron Katie says that to
believe that you need what you don't
have is the definition of insanity to
believe that you need what you don't
have because you're already here so
you've already proven that you don't
need it so the goal around believing
that I can't be happy fulfilled you know
whatever it is unless I get this stuff
that I don't already have it's a
complete and total illusion that's a
it's a thought that isn't even true
because there's no truth to it
whatsoever you don't need anything and
when you get that the irony is you're no
longer you're no longer attached you're
your total life is about it's just about
living those virtues how can I serve how
can I be sincere how can I be gentle how
can I be supportive and thinking like
that and that's how I think now and
because of that I'm in meaning and being
in meaning the times that I was in
ambition you know is
it's delivering more and more and more
and more of what I wanted so much then
and now that I'm not attached to it it's
like I can just be like the I can be
like the cat you know I can just go
about my business and just let it follow
after me wherever I go so what I say to
people who really want to access the the
transition from you know from ambition
to meaning if they really want to access
it is to get your thoughts off of
yourself I do it on the radio every
every month taken it it's like all my
questions you know all the questions are
about why can't I manifest this why
can't I have that this isn't working and
so on and my response back to them all
the time over and over again is take
what it is that you would really like to
attract into your life whatever it is
whether it's well a job you know money a
nice watch a new car whatever it is and
want it more for somebody else than you
want it for yourself just just want it
more just think about that and think
about how much joy it would give you to
be able to put your attention on that
and just keep your thoughts on that you
know take your thoughts off of yourself
and start living the four virtues start
being sincere start being supportive you
know start having this reverence
reverence for it for their life intro
and just shift off of what's in it for
me you know and how much am I going to
get and why isn't it here fast enough
and how much else and why is there
shinier than mine you know and so on off
of that and and begin to project that
and do that I don't care whether you're
a school teacher it does I don't care if
your dental hygienist or if you're a
carpenter or you know whatever it is out
there that you are doing if you can take
your attention here if you want the door
to open if you want the door to open to
meaning then the only way that door is
going to open is if you understand that
you have to leave your attachment to
this grossly world of the material
things and what's in it for me and how
much am I getting and shift your energy
your thoughts onto how may I offer how
may I serve and I just had to do I just
did a public television special another
public television special and when I got
an hour and a half before the show to
start
I was in I got one of these attacks
again in the neck and I was just like
you know how am I going to get through
this thing and so on and I I said a
prayer my wife was there two of my girls
were there we were in the room I had my
arms around them and I said if I'm
supposed to endure this pain you know
for whatever reason that I don't even
understand you and I'm willing to do it
but could I please just have the next
couple of hours so that I could at least
get through this experience and it just
is on and I was able you were there you
were in the audience and I was able to
go out there and do it and then the pain
returned the next day and I went right
back to that state and I still do it now
and I can I can feel that even now as
we're talking about a little bit here
and instead of cursing it instead of
being angry at it I accept it as as my
Dhamma this is you know and whatever it
is that I have to learn from it
generally speaking every difficulty I've
had in my life and getting divorced
literally being someone who is addicted
to substances including alcohol letting
go of you know those kinds of beliefs
that those are terrible things that I
should be ashamed of even amongst my
greatest teachers and this pain is just
another one of those things and
generally speaking I now can go out and
help people who live in chronic pain and
you do a lot of this with her to happen
you know Peter I've seen you do it on
stage you know with people when we're
cycling around Australia that one woman
what was it she couldn't even well
there's one lady with a frozen shoulder
right I've been able to move her arm in
year year and 20 minutes together yeah I
like that yeah so it's like and that
comes from just accepting yourself and
actually instead of cursing the pain
because when you curse the pain and get
angry at it you just you get anger every
cell of your being goes through that
same angry and what you want to do is
just get to that peaceful place within
yourself where you say you know when
your trust in yourself when your trust
in yourself you're really trusting in
the wisdom that created you oh no and
the wisdom that created you is infinite
well and it's formless and so your
thoughts are in that same category have
thoughts that are aligned with that
divine
the divine presence yeah you'll see it
going away the obscure outlast the
obvious try to become a little more
obscure a little less interfering a
little less notice me a little less you
know one of the specific kinds of things
that you can do is just as you're about
when somebody else is talking just as
you're about to interject what you've
been thinking about for the whole time
waiting for them to stop talking just to
just stop to bite your tongue and say
tell me more or that's very interesting
I have never heard that point of view
before even if they totally completely
disagree with everything that you stand
for to be to be willing to listen to
being able to stop practice it I
practice it when I did these verses of
the doubt I practice it every single day
while I was working on that
just staying obscure and for me that's
not always so easy because of just being
recognized wherever I go and if I saw
someone was about to recognize me I
would just put my head down I just walk
a little bit past them like something
right now I just want to be anonymous
right now I want to be obscured all
things are possible
and I always ask an audience what does
that leave out you know that all things
are possible literally means all things
are possible
so whatever whatever it is you'd like to
attract into your life whatever you'd
like to accomplish whatever you'd like
to do in your life if you start from a
spiritual place a place of all things
are possible if I return you know and
get to that place and then I begin to
visualize this and I begin to use my
imagination because everything that we
see around us everything in this world
was once imagined everything you know
that camera that is there the clothes
that you're wearing the chairs that were
sitting on everything once had to be
imagined if you get that I mean
Einstein's famous observation was that
you know imagination is more important
than knowledge if you can learn how
important your imagination is and that's
where your spirit is in that place and
then once you go to that place in what
it is you'd like to attract into your
life you're coming from a spiritual
place absolutely nothing is impossible
I was Thomas Howard I don't know he did
some lectures on mental science way back
in the night
you know 7:00 1908 he was from Scotland
and one of the things that he said he
said that the Delta the law of flotation
was not discovered by the contemplation
of the sinking of things so that you
know like before the 15th and 16th
centuries all of the ships were made out
of wood not because iron wasn't
available and steel wasn't available but
because there was a belief that would
float it so therefore you had to make
ships out of things that floated that's
literally held and then someone came
along and said that it has absolutely
nothing to do with what things are made
out of it has to do with the amount of
water that is being dispersed that's
that's what determines whether something
will float or not and I think about that
all the time because it's it's in the
contemplation of what you desire that
you create what it is that you want to
have for your subjects and your
willingness to contemplate it and
nothing more according to towered in
mental science so that I think about the
Wright brothers you know 100 or so years
ago you know it's like and I said the
law of flying was not discovered by the
contemplation of the staying on the
ground of things so that these were two
people like for me to figure out how to
get an airplane to fly and my limited
knowledge of all that I would probably
have contemplated the staying on the
ground of things you know this is what
happened but there's somebody came along
and contemplated the idea that if you
get enough speed going and you have the
right design and you get pressure
underneath something like this and you
get look that this thing is going to
lift up off the earth
somebody had to contemplate that idea
and everybody who contemplated that it
wasn't possible that it couldn't work
was a part of why flying didn't take
place because there was no law
discovered in the in the early part of
the 20th century any more than
electricity was discovered by Thomas
Edison or anyone like that I mean the
ability to have electricity has always
been there somebody has to contemplate
so it's like in your own personal life
your willingness to contemplate yourself
as a person who is capable of attracting
into your life what you want having the
kind of relationships that you want
being able to have abundance where where
you know scarcity always exists all you
have to do is begin the process by
having by being willing to contemplate
the presence of that in your life and
I've always been a person that I can
remember throughout my life as someone
who could contemplate myself being able
to do things that most people couldn't I
can give you a good example when I was
when my mother got us all back together
and we were living in Detroit on the
east side of Detroit and we got a new
television set it was a black-and-white
it was a screen about this big it was an
admiral and we had it in her home and it
was like oh my god black-and-white
television you know you remember Uncle
Miltie and that Alden fella and there
was a guy that was on TV
his name was Steve Allen and he was on
The Tonight Show and I was 11 12 13
years old I was born in 1940 so 61 or 52
and I used to stay up every night and
watch The Tonight Show and even though I
had to go to school the next day I was
just something about that show and you
know all of the characters and proxmark
and all the things that the Steve Allen
would do on it
and I would come down when I would be
talking the next day and I would be
telling my mother and my two brothers
that when I do the Tonight Show this is
what I would say I wouldn't have said
the world what Louie NYE say the way we
reacted how he reacted that I would have
said it and I used to do this and my
brothers and my mother would say to them
that's just way and he's just got this
nutty he he thinks he's on the Tonight
Show he thinks he's going to do the
Tonight Show and I would go up into my
room but you know on this little tiny
house that we lived in in a little
two-bedroom house that five of us lived
in because my mother remarried and and I
would just I would see myself doing the
Tonight Show I could just practice it
and Steve Allen became someone that I
was really an amateur well you know fast
forward
thirty years or whatever so and that's a
I've written a book you're erroneous
zones and the Tonight Show calls and
they asked me if I would like to come on
a bit so I do my first stint on The
Tonight Show I did the show like 37
times over a period of three or four
years with all these different hosts but
Johnny Carson was on and the the first
guest on the very first show when I did
the show was with Steve Allen and it was
like something clicked in me that I had
contemplated that as a child I had
always had a knowing and I can remember
sitting there talking to Johnny about
this thing that you know like Steve
Allen was sitting there right next to me
and we were talking about that kind of
so that by putting my attention on
something I wasn't some deliberate thing
that I was doing you know when I was 11
or 12 years old that was designating
that I was going to be a person who was
going to be appearing on talk shows
thirty years from now it was just an
awareness to a willingness to
contemplate to contemplate myself in
that kind of a place and I think the
power of contemplation is the thing that
most people haven't harnessed yet and
when we do when you harness it in your
life there's absolutely no limit to what
you can attract into your life if you
absolutely stay focused on what it is
that you know you're going to manifest
and attract you're not going to do it in
in your time you know Jackson Browne
sings a song it says in creation reveals
its secrets
by and by I mean you can't push the
river you can't it's all done in divine
time but it will show it will show it
will manifest it will attract itself and
I'm never surprised any longer about
anything that I put my thoughts on that
I can attract it into my life I just
absolutely know that law of attraction
and that it absolutely works giving up
your personal history and I learned it
from a man named Carlos Castaneda who
once said that one day he said I finally
realized that I no longer needed a
personal history and just like drinking
he said I gave it up and that and only
that has made all the difference in the
world you know the nice thing about
giving up your personal history
is that if you don't have a story you
don't have to live up to it all of us
have these bags the manure that we carry
around with us called our pass and the
people who have done things to us and
the events and the circumstances all of
this stuff that we use and we bond to
and we bond ourselves to these wounds of
our past and we identify yourself on the
basis of these wounds and every once in
a while we set it down and we reach in
there and we smear it all over ourselves
and then we wonder why does my life
smell so bad I don't understand when in
fact the now this moment merging
yourself into the now means that you may
have been in a relationship I had a
woman from Holland who came over to see
me whose husband had left her after 25
years she had four children and she just
had been on the verge of suicide and she
was losing weight and she was depressed
and she was taking all kinds of drugs
for it and she was getting sicker and
sicker because she just couldn't get
over it and she came to a book signing
that I was doing at a bookstore down in
Florida and she said you've got to say
something to me you've got to say
something to me that will help me to get
over this and I told her this line
I said give up your personal history
merge yourself here now into this moment
and those 25 years are something if you
want to understand how to do it think of
your past as oh this hat and this is
your past now you can't just set this
thing down over here and walk away from
it and give up your personal history
because you'll always have it there to
look back at what you do is you pick up
your past and you embrace it you
understand it you accept it as I had to
go through these things that I had to go
through in order for me to get to this
place today and the evidence for that is
that I
did you don't need any more evidence you
did and then you toss it you toss it you
embrace it and you toss it and you merge
into the now by giving up your
attachment and some of you have heard me
use the metaphor of the wake Alan Watts
talked about the wake is not what drives
the boat the wake is just a trail that
is left behind that's all it is and so
is the wake of your life and the wake
doesn't make the boat go and neither
does the wake of your life the reason
why your life is going in the direction
that it is the wake is a trail that is
left behind and it's an illusion to
believe that it is the cause of your
suffering or your struggles or your
difficulty give it up let it go
embrace it understand it get help doing
that if you must and then move into the
now thinking small is what gets great
things done verse 63 achieve greatness
in little things take on difficulties
while they are still easy do great
things while they are still small
the sage visaed one of my daughter's
names the sage does not attempt anything
very big and thus achieves greatness
greatness comes from being in the moment
here present in the now the sage
confronts difficulties but never
experiences them this is the idea of
thinking small and finally I'd like to
see you change from this thought change
from seeing yourself as separate to
seeing yourself as connected to everyone
and everything in the universe I set and
read an essay called the whole man by
Abraham Maslow
and Maslow was the first person that had
ever seen in the field of psychology who
spoke about we should not be assessing
who human beings are and what they're
capable of doing based upon what's
missing or what's wrong or what they
can't do or their weaknesses
study neurology neurological disorders
we shouldn't study the how psychotic
people are or how neurotic they are we
should look at the greatest achievers
who've ever walked among us know that
they all came from the same intelligence
and recognized and helped people to find
that within themselves and as I read
this essay I was so taken by it and he
talked about the qualities or the
characteristics of what he called self
actualizing people and he said the
number one quality and characteristic of
these people who live at the apex of
what he called self-actualization who
are way beyond just taking care of their
biological needs who are way our bond
beyond their social needs who are wave
beyond needing to be loved and so on
these are people who came here with a
purpose these are people who have a
dharma these are people who won't let
anyone else determine what it is they're
going to be he said their number one
quality of these people is that they are
independent of the good opinion of other
people they listen to an inner voice yes
our physical body is what it is but we
can make choices about it
yes our spiritual body our purpose our
Dharma what we're here for
it's also doomed but we make choices
what are the choices you came here to be
a great artist I did a whole film on
this is called the shift and this whole
idea is that q you came here to be a
great artist do you pick up a paintbrush
do you do what van Gogh did you just go
out there and and and paint because it's
in your soul because the second
characteristic of self actualizing
people according to Maslow is that they
are detached from outcome they don't do
what they do because of what result is
going to come to them because of how
much money they're going to make almost
prestige they're going to get how big
their business is going to grow that is
not what motivates self actualized
people what motivates self actualizing
people is this is my calling
I found myself reading the bhagavad-gita
for the third time in the last three
months
I just keep reading it over not just
like when I did the Dow eight years ago
when I turned 65 and couldn't stop it
and the teachers showed up the Buddhist
proverb is that when the student is
ready the teachers will appear it's not
whether there's teachers there there's
teachers everywhere there everything is
a teaching the question isn't whether
the teachers are there the question is
how willing are you to pay attention how
willing are you to listen to that inner
voice that no one else can hear that
little scurvy elephant in there that
says you're not the boss of me you can't
tell me what I'm here for you have to it
takes a kind of fearlessness because
fear is such a omnipresent force in our
lives I do what I do because of the
passion I feel I am not here because of
what you paid me to be here for I am not
here because of any need that I have to
sell another book I'm not here for
anything external to myself I am here
because I have a passion within me
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because I Bea Hadid
asked me to also if you want to nominate
someone for the next top 10 video please
check the description for a link to
video where you can vote for people and
put in your suggestions as well I'd love
to know what did you take from this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow
please leave it down the comments below
I'm super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Dave
Gardner from B David Gardner comm Dave
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word taking that
picture sending it in I really really
appreciate your support man and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
the ego is not worth defending and and
and we all spend a lot of our time
defending this thing that says what you
know I am what I do have and I have to
get more things and if I don't have as
much as they do then they're going to
and we go through our lives doing all of
this stuff and what it does is it brings
us to a point where we no longer have
something or our reputation is gone or
taken away from us or somebody steals it
and what happens to us or when we retire
or you know any no longer can do things
so now people get over a certain age and
they just feel like you know I've
declined and so there's nothing in the
DNA that says you have to decline ever
in your life you don't have to decline
in your DNA is over 600000 why do we
have it though why do we have it we have
it because it works it works to get it
getting ourselves believing that we're
better than other people
instead of just allowing ourselves to be
free and that's it's like it's like now
ISM the dow teaches us to like until the
onion on peel layers to get that the
essence of the dow is emptiness getting
to that place of emptiness that's like
the supreme place to get to were you
just empty of all of that and then
you're free and then guess what all of
the things that you wanted so
desperately when you were so eagle
dominated before begin to show up in
larger and larger and larger mother